so much for hiatus it's pft live pftpm
pft whatever you want to call us
i've got some things to say and we have
the technology to allow me
to say it let's get to some of the news
currently happening in the nfl and then
i'll answer
some of the questions that were
submitted via twitter
one of the big stories on one of the
slowest days of the year
the announcement by the washington
football team that tonya snyder the
wife of daniel snyder is now co-ceo and
co-owner
of the team many have wondered what in
the world is going on why was this
something that happened now
snyder's owned the team for over 20
years and this move hadn't happened
before then
a lot of speculation that maybe at some
point
daniel snyder gets nudged out of
ownership so his wife can take over
there's still that lingering
investigation i don't buy that
speculation
i think that plain and simple
this move is a recognition of the
reality
that the values of these franchises will
be mushrooming in the coming years
i had an owner tell me last year that
before too long thanks to legalized
gambling
the value of the average run-of-the-mill
team is going to be in the range of 8 to
10
billion with a b that creates a problem
when someone who owns the team dies
you have to come up with a huge payment
for
the estate taxes and there have been
multiple occasions in the past including
at one point the washington football
team jack kent cook
his family had to sell because of the
inability to pay the estate taxes
without selling off
the team as that asset becomes more and
more valuable on paper
that drives up the estate tax obligation
and it makes it
impossible in some cases for enough cash
to be available
to satisfy the estate tax requirement
so if there are co-owners if the equity
has been moved around if it's
easier and cheaper from the standpoint
of
one spouse passing the other still
living that kicks the can that gives
the family time to make other
arrangements other
plans to soften the blow of the estate
tax obligation
when and this is one of the things that
i've heard over and over again
the children of daniel and tanya snyder
end up
inheriting and running the team it
becomes more challenging to preserve the
ability to do that
at a time when the value of the average
nfl franchise is going
up and up and up due to increased
revenues due to
gambling opportunities due to everything
that makes the nfl what it's been
and that's one of the concerns that's
out there for the league
generally what changes to the ownership
structure may be necessary to make it
easier for families to continue to own
teams
minimum percentage that someone must own
in order to control a team and own a
team and run a team
we may see that drop corporate ownership
may be
something that is out there on the
horizon at some point
and one of the challenges finding people
who have enough money to buy
and to run an nfl team as the teams get
more and more expensive it's going to be
harder and harder to find someone who
can step
in and and pay the amount
that's going to be required as these
values continue to
go up and up so i i think that may have
something to do with it
also remember snyder took on a bunch of
debt recently in order to buy out his
disgruntled
minority partners and
there's talk that that's going to be a
significant obligation
for him to satisfy and we'll see if the
cash flow in the short term
allows it i don't know that this
ownership move with his wife has
anything to do with that
but just keep an eye on that wrinkle as
well a significant debt obligation
assumed by snyder in order to finally
solve the problem
that was presented by three minority
partners who desperately wanted out and
were creating
plenty of issues now snyder owns it all
but
owning it all means owning it all and it
means
positioning yourself to deal with that
estate tax
obligation when the time comes to figure
out how much uncle sam gets when someone
who
owns something worth multiple billions
of dollars leaves
the planet the ncaa isn't
gone from the planet yet but it's moving
in that direction
the name image and likeness issue coming
to a head this week
as the ncaa has decided wisely to let
each school make its own decisions about
what the rules will be when it comes to
the ability of players
to make money from their fame that they
enjoy
by playing college sports or otherwise
you may have some
people who end up in college athletics
who already
amassed a certain amount of fame on
social media platforms or otherwise the
bottom line is your eligibility is not
going to be affected now
by generating revenue from name image
and likeness
some schools may have different rules
than other schools
but that'll become a recruiting
impediment
if one team decides to be very
restrictive then another team another
school
less restrictive more likely to get the
players
that it wants one hidden benefit to this
for college football
and indirectly for the nfl to the extent
the nfl
wants to encourage college football
players to stay in school as long as
they can
and the nfl does try to encourage that i
think as a way
to placate the people responsible for
the free farm system that is college
football
the nfl wants college coaches
to not be unhappy with the nfl the
college coaches
shouldn't think that the nfl is trying
too hard to lure players to leave
because the nfl teams need full
cooperation from the college programs to
get the game film
access to practices etc so i think if
the nfl
had its way there would be no early
entries into the draft if the league had
its way
of course the teams would like to have a
crack at underclassmen who are eligible
to jump to the draft but the point is
this
with the nil laws coming into
place with the schools being allowed by
the ncaa to
come to their own conclusions as to what
the procedures will be
you could have some of the most popular
college football players
making enough money from their fame as
college football players to say hey
i don't need to leave i can stay here in
tuscaloosa
in tallahassee in gainesville in
stillwater in wherever
and generate as much money maybe more
as the big fish in a fairly big pond but
not nearly as big as the nfl
how many times do we see a guy who was a
superstar for a college team
get absorbed into the nfl and become
anonymous become an afterthought become
a oh i remember when that guy
was a much more significant player
in the world of college football it's
going to be a factor it's not going to
drive decisions
but i think it will definitely be a
factor because now when you make the
decision
whether or not to leave school early
what are you giving up
at most you're giving up the chance that
one more year of college football
will cause you to be drafted higher and
that's part of the analysis
now you're also giving up whatever money
you could make in that extra year so
it's a complicated decision it's another
factor
these players need to be surrounded by
people who really care about their best
interests and aren't trying to feather
their own nests make their own money
steer guys toward a decision
that is more likely to benefit the
person who is doing the nudging
but that's part of free enterprise and
the point that i made
because the ncaa wants congress to come
in and create a national law
that would establish rules for name
image and likeness revenue my point is
this and i don't like it when people say
this generally because i think it's a
lazy way to tell
congress not to worry about things that
it really
should be worrying about the old doesn't
congress have better things to do
line but in this instance i look at it
this way
you've got actors 18 19 20 years old
nobody regulates their ability to
capitalize on their fame
through whatever means are available
musicians nobody regulates their ability
to sell autographs do appearances make
money off of social media
why is it different for for an athlete
why there should be no difference this
whole thing is
an ongoing outgrowth of the facade of
amateurism
and that facade needs to be imploded
once and for all and once we accept that
fact
that it's there's no purity of college
sport because the people aren't being
paid i think it should be open season
and i don't think the ncaa should have
the ability
to lobby congress and basically get
congress to put in place
nationally the rules that the ncaa would
put in place
on its own but if the ncaa does it now
it's stepping right
into an antitrust violation so
i i hope that's not what happens and i i
hope that congress decides to save the
ncaa
this is your mess you created it
now you deal with it we have no
compulsion and no desire and no need to
take up
our time coming up with a rule that
ultimately gets
your ass out of the hot water that
you've been sitting in
without anyone really noticing all these
years well now they're noticing and now
hopefully these kids will be able to get
fair value
if not from the schools and hopefully
that's coming fair value from the fame
that they deserve based upon their
unique skills and abilities as played
out on football fields
from c to shining c june 29
is the 38th anniversary of the death of
joe delaney every year we remember him
at profootballtalk.com for one
reason actually two first one is
every year that we write a story about
joe delany or talk about joe delaney the
chiefs player who gave his life
drowned while trying to save three young
children june 29 1983
in louisiana his home state he'd been
the nfl's
rookie of the year in 1981 very
promising career
had over 1100 yards rushing in his first
season
threw it all away willingly courageously
entered that water even though he
couldn't swim in an effort to save the
three children ultimately saved one of
them ultimately gave his life
every time i talk about that story at
pft i hear from someone who says
i'd never heard it before and that's all
the more reason to bring it up each and
every year it's a
example of true heroism that needs to be
celebrated and
i continue to believe that the nfl needs
to do something more
something at all i'm not aware of
anything the nfl has done at all
to memorialize joe delaney is there a
reward not a reward but an award
that could be named after joe delaney is
there something that can be done at the
hall of fame
something that makes every football fan
aware of what joe delaney did and
something that honors
the spirit of selflessness that he
clearly was armed with on that day when
plenty of people were standing around
while the three children drowned and joe
delaney even though as he said
at the time i don't swim very well ran
into the water in his effort to do what
he could and ultimately gave his life i
just think it's something that
that everyone needs to know about that's
why we mention it every year on june
29th
maybe at some point we won't need to
mention it every year on june 29 because
maybe at some point it'll be so well
known by the existence of an award
by the existence of some honor by the
existence of some memorial
that football fans know about it not
just on june 29
but all year long all right i asked for
some questions today
let's answer some questions let's see
what we got here
via twitter a red zone out one of our
most loyal
and trusted question askers from
across the atlantic ocean will aaron
rodgers be following russell wilson's
lead and dismissing all the controversy
obviously we don't know what what aaron
rodgers is going to do russell wilson
showed up during
ota showed up for mandatory mini camp
and created the impression that
everything is fine whatever it was that
was going on
back in february and march wilson
downplayed it
wilson is fine and and i think wilson
recognizes
this is season number 10 he wants to add
to his legacy
he has to make chicken salad out of a
situation that he regards
at least regarded last year as something
other than chicken salad
and he seems to be happy with the new
offense under
coordinator shane waldron and maybe they
can
establish and maintain momentum this
year remember early in 2020
seahawks offense very good defenses
caught up with them shane waldron's job
is going to be to keep himself ahead of
the defenses as they begin to figure out
what the seahawks are doing
so wilson wilson's problem wasn't with
any one person in the front office it
was just the overall approach
he wants to be the guy through whom the
offense runs he wants to be used more
like patrick mahomes
and less like a game manager who's
relying upon a great defense
and a great running game which wilson
obviously is part of but we see less
running as he gets older
one thing sims has noticed is he's not
he's not as fast as he used to be and it
could just be those other quarterbacks
in the nfl who are faster and so
by comparison wilson looks less fast but
the bottom line is wilson isn't
at a point where his relationship with
anyone in management is fractured
with rogers it feels like that
relationship with mark murphy and or
brian gudekunst
is fractured and maybe can't be repaired
now the question is
can roger show up for his teammates for
his coaches for the fans
and go through the motions for one more
year ignoring his issues with management
something i've said multiple times over
the past few weeks
who in america doesn't have some issue
with someone in management wherever they
work i love my job
but you know the the the boss is kind of
a jerk but i can deal with that because
i love my co-workers
i love my immediate supervisor i like
what i'm doing so i can set that aside
that's the challenge for aaron rodgers
can he set it aside i still think he
will
i think he'll show up and is there a
chance
he'll blame us the media for making a
big deal
about something that he made a big deal
about something that once it became a
big deal he did nothing
to quiet it down if anything he stirred
the pot
oh i i fully expect that he'll be
standing in front of his locker we know
the shot
and he'll be taking shots at those of us
who had nothing better to do
than speculate on aaron rodgers future
whether he'd be back how long he'll stay
will he get a trade does he want to
trade who does he want to be traded to
it's it's one great dynamics of modern
sports where
certain athletes want and crave
attention
and they want to reserve the right to
resent the attention
that they receive i think that's
probably going to happen
at some point in late july when aaron
rodgers shows up and i think he will
show up remember he has until july 2
to opt out for all of the 2021 season
with no financial consequence other than
obviously not getting paid his salary
but he wouldn't have to pay back signing
bonus money he'd still make his roster
bonus of 6.8 million he's already earned
it he gets paid out weekly all season
long
hell he'll make more than most players
if he opts out
but i'm told that it's unlikely he'll do
that because it's too soon to make that
kind of a decision that you're not going
to play at all i think he's still
holding out hope
that the packers will decide just go
ahead and trade him
we're going to trade him next year
anyway let's go ahead and trade him now
see what we have in jordan love
and aaron rodgers finally gets what he
wants next question pftp on posse have
you seen anything from cowboys head
coach mike mccarthy that gives you
confidence in him well he did win a
super bowl
let's not forget that i know it's been a
long time ago
grand scheme of things it's been a blink
of an eye was the 2010 season
super bowl 45 packers did beat the
steelers
now have i seen anything in dallas that
makes me think he's the long-term answer
well
when your franchise quarterback breaks
his ankle week five and you're stuck
with andy dalton the rest of the way all
due respect and your defense is
historically bad
what chance do you really have i mean
last year for a lot of coaches for a lot
of teams i think was just kind of a
weird strange
upside down existence i think this year
we'll get a better look at what mike
mccarthy brings to the table
dan quinn in is the defensive
coordinator dak prescott if he stays
healthy
will the cowboys be competitive they're
the favorites to win the nfc east i
don't think they should be but they're
the cowboys and they'll always be the
cowboys i don't care how bad they get
they will continue to be the cowboys and
one thing that jerry jones has in common
probably the only thing he has in common
with mike brown the owner of the bengals
neither guy likes to pay head coaches to
not work
so i don't think mccarthy's on the hot
seat by any means this year because he's
got several years left on his contract
but i think we'll get an idea this year
as to whether or not he really is suited
to
become potentially the only coach
to win a super bowl with two different
teams did it with the packers think
about it no coach has ever
won a super bowl with two different
teams we'll get an idea this year
whether or not mike mccarthy's on that
track or whether he's on the track to be
the next cowboys coach
to inevitably be replaced by someone
else
at bourbon street saints will the saints
go with jameis winston taysom hill
or both i i've said this as it relates
to the patriots
i could see bill belichick who is the
master of coming up with
game specific attacks offensively and
defensively
choosing mack jones one week cam newton
the next based upon the match-ups
could sean payton do that could sean
payton look at a defense and say
we can attack this defense better with
jameis winston
he's the starter this week then the next
week well we can attack this defense
better with taysom hill
he's the start of this week i don't
think it'll happen but it is
one option that's available and the
thing about going with jameis winston
if you do that you still have full
access to the taysom hill package
if taysom hill's the starter it's not
like you have a jameis winston package
although i could see both guys being
used
in the same game on the same play
potentially regardless of who the
starter is the one thing that
sims and i have talked about multiple
times before we went on our pft live
hiatus
the ability of the starting quarterback
to process the plays that sean payton
identifies develops draws up on the back
of a napkin the morning of a game
how quickly you can adapt and adjust and
run that play during the game
the more likely that quarterback is
going to be to become
the eventual starter and keep that job
another question or two houston no
matter what how realistic is the
possibility deshaun watson suits up for
houston this fall
i don't think it's very realistic i
think the only way it happens
is if the nfl refuses to provide any
clarity
as to whether or not deshaun watson is
going to be placed
on paid leave that's step one now i
think the league should
tell the texans watson and any other
team that would be potentially trading
for him
yes or no will he be placed on paid
leave the league has had three and a
half months and counting
to investigate they should know by now
whether or not this falls into the
category of paid leave
they need to let everyone know but if
they don't if they don't
and watson decides you know what i can
hold out
stay away lose a ton of money have to
pay back bonus money be fined
lose my salary or i can show up
and then if i get placed on paid leave i
don't have to pay any money back
don't get fined and i get my salary of
more than 10 million dollars and i don't
play for the texans this year so
if he's forced to place a bet on paid
leave or not paid leave and he chooses
the path of paid leave
and they don't put him on paid leave he
shows up for the texans they don't put
him on paid leave
he's a texans quarterback he's stuck at
that point
that's the one way that this happens
that the dominoes fall in a manner that
results in number four
in red and blue playing for the texans
this year i don't think it's a likely
scenario in part because i think the
league does owe it even if they don't
announce it publicly they owe it to
everyone involved
to to privately say
yeah if he shows up he's getting put on
paid leave or no if he if he shows up
we're not putting him on paid leave
that's the key point and i think by the
time we get to late july
hopefully the league will let everyone
know and then they can make their
decisions accordingly but the one way
the one way that watson ends up with the
texans
they don't have clarity he guesses he's
going to be put on paid leave
he shows up and he's not put on paid
leave
all right let's see if we have one more
here mccorkle jones opinion on the
patriots you think they can win the
division and make a super bowl run this
year i think they can why
why not last year was a down year feels
like they were three and 13.
they were seven and nine they were in
pretty much every game
they go out and spend like never before
on veterans
at areas of weakness they get their key
opt-outs back like dante hightower i
know patrick chung retired but dante
hightower was the guy they missed the
most
now they've got cam newton's second year
in the system with better weapons around
him
mac jones there to push him maybe they
do use both guys throughout the course
of the year
and and one thing we learned last year
bill belichick's not bashful about
benching
cam newton if cam newton's not getting
it done and cam newton has the respect
necessary for bill belichick to not get
upset if it happens
so yeah i think the patriots
could be much better than last year and
because of the presence of bill
belichick and josh mcdaniels matt
patricia who's now back in a very
diverse role where he's
helping the broader effort any way he
can
this is a team that last year managed to
win seven games
with not very good talent at all this
year with improved talent
with belichick yeah this could be a team
that that makes some noise
and thrusts itself back into the
conversation in a very top-heavy afc
that's the thing about the afc this year
you've got six
seven teams that you could make a case
for as super bowl participants
the bills the patriots the browns
the ravens the steelers maybe maybe
the titans the colts i haven't even
gotten to the afc
west the chiefs and the chargers you got
more than half the conference
you could say yeah you know what it
could fall together just right and that
team gets to the super bowl the nfc
if especially if aaron rodgers doesn't
show up and i think he will
let's say he does bucks packers
then who rams with matthew stafford
i don't know we kind of need to see how
it all plays out 49ers
if they stay healthy well that's a big
if and this whole jimmy garoppolo tray
lance thing
i i just think that the path in the afc
is so much
more difficult than the nfc and it's
going to require
some big moments big games big decisions
key coaching keeping everyone at an even
keel i mean it all adds up
because the patriots do have the talent
it adds up to the patriots being in the
mix
and maybe because of their history
especially among the coaching staff a
lot of players
working their way in who haven't been
there to the top of the mountain yet but
the coaching staff has been there
knows how to manage the guys for
situations like this i think that the
patriots are a team to keep an eye on
that that could find a way to navigate
this very difficult afc field in 2021
that's it for today we'll try to do this
again
tomorrow thursday i ain't doing it
because i'm getting my vampire wisdom
tooth
yanked thursday morning if the
swelling's down by friday and i can
speak co-currently not that i can't any
other time
we'll do one then for now though until
tomorrow thanks for some of your time
check us out around the clock at
profootballtalk.com even though pft live
and pftpm are on hiatus
we'll be here for you every step of the
way training camps coming
season will be here before you know it
thanks as always for some of your time
we'll see you again real soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports